the family of an Arkansas man is suing
the jail he died in the family claims he
was denied adequate medical care
Michael sabi died in 2015 just days
after he was locked up at the bi-state
Justice Center police arrested him over
a verbal dispute with his wife the
following video taken hours before he
died may be disturbing to watch this was
recorded by a jail staffer it appears to
show Savi's heavy breathing and weak
condition as he was taken back to his
cell Omar Villafranca is outside the
jail and Texarkana Texas along the
Arkansas border
Omar good morning good morning Michael
sapis family says that jail knew he had
serious medical conditions and did not
get him help when he needed it Savi's
attorney gave us video from inside the
jail that appears to show his state
about 12 hours before he was found dead
it's worth noting CBS News has not been
able to independently confirm the
video's authenticity surveillance video
given to CBS News from Michael Savi's
attorney appears to show a security
guard at the bi-state Justice Center
throws Abby to the ground according to
the lawsuit
Sabby wasn't feeling well and had
stopped to lean against the wall before
attempting to enter the booking area to
make a phone call a second video taken
by a jail employee purportedly shows
what happened after Savi is on the floor
he's held down by six guards and
pepper-sprayed brought to a jail nurse
for less than a minute rinsed off and
returned to his cell during the nine and
a half minutes video Sabby says he can't
breathe at least 19 times and asked for
water
the next morning jail guards found a 35
year old dead on his jail cell floor
he's a medically vulnerable person so he
reported at at intake that he had
hypertension diabetes heart disease and
asthma Eric Hite is representing Savi's
family in a lawsuit against the jail
filed earlier this week the suit claims
jail staff didn't give sabhi his
medications ignored his labored
breathing and used excessive force
LaSalle Corrections run
this privately-owned Jail and 17 other
facilities across four states they said
they do not make comments on pending
litigation but told a local news station
last October that they comply with the
Texas Jail Commission standards hypeeee
says the family wants justice and
answers for the father of four they want
to expose what happened in the hopes
that this sort of thing doesn't happen
to anyone else according to jail
protocol somebody was supposed to check
on sabhi every 30 minutes overnight the
suit claims that a guard said she did
but then later admitted to lying
Nora really disturbing story Omar thank
you so much